Jets Gary vuk
folks thank you my man thank you man wow
hey before we go you got to get into the
to the to the real work right there is a
um there's a team here in Australia
called the IP switch Jets okay I grew up
in ipswitch right it's kind of like now
in America what would be a town do they
stink like my
Jets now the have a look at their logo
right well look at oh my logo's not
there damn it okay so here's their logo
on the JY I love it a look at that
switch Jets I love it so uh he's going
to own the New York Jets I might buy the
I switch Jets I don't know thank you
Gary ve give it
up thanks for having me um so I'm super
excited for the Q&A part and I'm going
to try to rush into that as quickly as
possible um but I'll give you a little
bit of my Spiel uh what's on my mind
right now and then uh and then hopefully
we can go into that Q&A um I think the
first thing I want to talk about is the
fact that I think we're living through
one of the biggest culture shifts of our
time I mean look 30% of this audience
right now is using a cell phone to
record this conversation and are looking
at this talk through their device which
I'm all for don't put it away I actually
think that's exactly right and I think
that one of the Great misnomers
uh for example so many of you are doing
online business you talk you know you
get taught or you get talking about how
do you monetize from your website this
that and the other thing and the next 24
to 36 months most people are going to
consume the entire internet through a
mobile device yet most of your websites
are completely optimized for desktop
computers and laptops right this is the
thing that I spend all my time on what
is really happening with consumer
behavior that most people aren't fully
adjusting in to where is the Arbitrage
the only thing I do for a living and why
I have the audacity to think that I can
buy a multi-billion dollar sports team
is that all my success has come from a
very simple move which is day trading
attention my asset the thing that I most
care about really uh you know if you sit
in this room and don't understand the
importance of this asset you'll become
vulnerable and not have as much upside
the entire game is predicated on
attention before you can tell me how
great your listing is that you're
selling or how great your product is or
how you how amazing your 9we course is
before you tell me how great your [__]
is you've got to actually get my
attention and in
2016 the supply and demand of attention
has become extremely difficult because
we are getting thrown at us so many
things we are now living in a world
where information is being pounded in
our face 24/7 365 live and the things
that are going to break through are
going to actually understand not only
that you have to produce great content
but way more importantly that you have
to understand the
context of the place where that person
is consuming the content if you're a
real practitioner in marketing you
understand there's a substantial
difference between a video that plays on
Facebook that plays on YouTube and that
plays on Snapchat these are
fundamentally different things my mind
mindset is different A 42-year-old
female in the United States that goes on
Pinterest and then 20 minutes later goes
on Facebook is the same woman with the
same income with the same scenarios but
her mindset is different when she's on
Pinterest cuz she's got aspiration to
buy things versus when she's on Facebook
because she's keeping up with her world
yet every day marketers in this room and
companies all over the world put the
same picture and video in her feed
thinking it's going to act the same way
my friends we are living through the
single biggest culture
shift single biggest culture shift of
end consumer attention since the
transition from the radio to the
television it's happening right in front
of you right this second and yet so many
people in this room live their lives one
way but they mark it a completely
different way right one of the things
that bothers me the most especially the
homework you know these 21-hour
traveling days allow you to catch up on
a lot of work and on the way here I paid
attention to a lot of the people in this
room that have been Tweeting or
Facebooking or emailing me that they
were going to be here and I took
advantage and was able to do three or
four hours of research to really pay
attention to what some of you guys are
doing in this room and to be very honest
with you and I and I apologize I didn't
want to come to Sydney to Raz but to be
very honest with you the far majority of
people in this room that are marketing
are Marketing in their best interest and
not in their consumer's best interest
the lack of patience the lack of content
that has anything to do with other than
what you want them to do is quite
stunning and would be a very quick
indicator to me that the return on the
investment is not as great as you'd like
it to be because you default into caring
about yourself first a lot of you have
consumed my stuff you've heard my Spiel
I'm a big believer that the people that
win deploy more value than they ask for
in return When You're deploying
well as I like to say 51% of the value
you win as a lot of you know I don't
play the game of masterminds or ebooks
or courses because I'm very comfortable
putting out my content for free and then
once every three years selling an $18
book you know I'm very comfortable in
that environment it's also the reason
that I think that I'm able to build
hundred million doll businesses that
don't require
me and really I'd like to pound that
thesis down this this Collective room I
think the one thing that I've noticed
has become very clear to me that is a
vulnerability and it R runs true across
a lot of demos is lack of patience if
you really asked me what's The Telltale
sign of somebody who's really winning or
is capable of winning versus not it's
completely predicated on patience you
know way too many people aren't
recognizing how about this how many
people in this room are retiring in the
next 10 years and I don't mean you're
going to crush
it I mean you're [__] old and you're
finished how many people in this room
are retiring in the next 10 years raise
your hand raise it high don't be scared
so for the six of you four of you you
could take a lot of what I'm about to
say with a grain of salt right but for
the majority of you I just want to
remind all of you that only 11 years ago
YouTube Facebook
smartphones Twitter Snapchat Instagram
it didn't
exist nothing existed 10 years ago that
is now at the Forefront of attention I
grew up actually how many people here
don't really know my Spiel raise your
hand just curious good amount great
perfect I'll go backwards then I grew up
um poor I was born in the Soviet Union I
came to the US when I was three um my
dad got a li got a job at a liquor store
and eventually saved a lot of money over
a seven-year period great shirt and uh
and uh oh and you too uh and uh and
eventually owned a small liquor store in
New Jersey I grew up an entrepreneur
very Hustler kid baseball cards
lemonades stands things like that I got
into my dad's business at 14 and at 17 I
fell in love with wine collecting I
realized that people collected wine the
way I collected baseball cards and
memorabilia and that became my passion
point to wanting to get involved in my
family business in 1996 I launched the
second ever e-commerce wine business in
America and from 1998 to 2005 in a
seven-year window I built my dad's
business from a three to a 65 million
year business so my first business was
retail bricks and mortar and e-commerce
not information not masterminds not
books not being me just being an
operator I didn't start talking about
business to the public until I was 34
years old I built my foundation in
building a tangible actual business
that's what I come from that's who I am
I'm currently the CEO of a 650 person
digital and social agency kind of a
Madison Avenue Madmen 2016 business I've
grown that business from a three to aund
million business in The Last 5 Years I'm
in the business of building businesses I
just happen to quite enjoy putting out
information that has an impact on people
along the way because very honestly and
this is quite simple I'm selfish off the
high that I get when I get an email from
somebody that has had something good
happen to them based on my business
advice that's that's where I'm at that's
like that's my life I don't thank
you I'm going to make a lot more money
on my Uber stock and on my Facebook
stock than I'll ever make being me or
selling a book or getting paid to speak
what I like is being historically
correct what I like is knowing that I
was gifted with a way to communicate
that actually gets through to people for
example 90% of the people in this room
are not willing to work as hard as their
ambition right I mean let's just cut to
the chase do you know how many of you
are full of straight
[__] like let's just cut right to the
chase you talk a big game of what you
want but you're not interested in doing
how many people in this room watch Daily
V my video blog raise your hand so what
this group knows versus the the half of
the room that or a third of the room
that raise their hands that don't know
me is that I work 18 hours a day 18
that's what I do because I talk a big
game and I want big things to happen and
so you actually have to put in the work
somebody in this room sent me a Snapchat
message a couple hours ago and saying
Gary talk to me about passive income let
me let me talk to all of you about
passive income it doesn't [__]
exist like there's there's no [__]
algorithm that's going to let you sit on
the [__] coast and drink [__]
champagne while the money comes rolling
in it doesn't exist and if it does
you're either doing something
illegal or something that would make
your spouse be embarrassed of who you
are I've been to enough [__]
marketing conferences where I've
literally watched the spouse of the
person on stage not feel comfortable
telling people how their husband or wife
makes money
I have no interest in having a legacy
that I can't be proud of I also have no
interest in telling you how to make your
money or how you live your life I have
no audacity or ability to even begin to
think about that but what I will tell
you is this my friends in a 2016 World
right in a 2016 world everybody in this
room is the patriarch and matriarch of
their family and I would tell you that I
live under a very aggressive thesis of
how you make your money is more
important than how much you make and I
feel as though one of the big messages
that needs to start being talked about
is some of the emotional intelligence
aspects of running a business I can
stand here very comfortably and tell a
lot of you that I'm not super iqed out I
I'm just not I'm not super smart when it
comes to just information retention of
[__] that's happened I've read seven
books I've written four right like like
I'm I'm
I'm I'm not that smart I'm really not
but what I can tell you is on the flip
side when it comes to the emotional
intelligence empathy self-awareness
gratitude intuition I'm all time as a
matter of fact in my will right now in
my Act of will it says if humans ever
figure out how to measure emotional
intelligence I want to be dug up and
tested
because because I can't explain to you
how I know that every person in this
room is going to be on Snapchat or that
every person is going to eventually like
I know for fact that everybody in this
room 20 years from now is going to be
sitting in their home or whatever we're
doing in 20 years and living through
virtual reality and that they'll be
struggling to understand if this is real
life or if virtual reality is real life
I also know that 80% of in this room
just heard me say that sentence and said
get the [__] out of
here in the same way that I stood in a
room like this in 1996 and said people
are going to buy wine on the internet
and everybody in this room laughed at me
because the guy that was sitting with me
on stage worked for the Yellow Pages I
don't know if they have that down here
but the yellow pages and made fun of me
and said who here he he we were
bantering and he goes actually he goes
who here will buy wine on the internet
and nobody ra could you imagine being
here right now and watching this entire
room nobody raises their hand and I
looked at him and I said honestly and
this was a different world I said I wish
this was being recorded because I will
be historically correct and all of you
will be historically wrong and so I do
that not because I'm smart not because I
know it's intuitive I can feel it I
watch it I see little things and I just
start to feel it and so here's what I
can feel I want to make my money in a
way that makes me proud because I don't
want to have the conversations with my
grandchildren about how I made my money
everybody here needs to understand
everything you're doing is being
documented all of it like every landing
page you create to convert someone
everything is being documented forever
and I'm watching so many of my
contemporaries and Friends chase money
over their good name over the way
they're going to feel and I'm very
concerned about it I I also know that
everything that you know today is being
disrupted heavily I know that the hotel
industry this Lovely Hotel you know the
the hotel I'm staying in I know that
five years ago none of them sat there
and said okay what's our biggest threat
in five years they were worried about
each other nobody nobody raised their
hand at the Four Seasons Hotel senior
staff meeting five years ago and said
what if somebody creates like an
eBay for people selling each other their
room rooms and their homes nobody saw
Airbnb coming in that industry the guy
or gal that owned the most taxi
medallions in New York City he or she
didn't sit around 5 years ago and said
you know somebody might create an app on
the iPhone where people going to hit the
button and a limo is going to come in
two minutes and pick them
up we are living email I literally
thought email was the most
indestructible core communication funnel
in our society how many people in the
screen room by show of hands are
familiar with slack or using
slack what's slack Google that
[__] we don't have time for that right
now one more time how many people know
slack you know I don't predict slack I
just look at slack and go holy [__] g
chat and email in my organization has
collapsed by 80% since we've installed
slack so then I text steuart Butterfield
C I'm like can I invest like like that's
what I do for a living and so we are
living through a much bigger culture
shift than this room is respecting and
so what I want to do is a couple things
number
one and Caleb it's fun to have you here
because I use it as a proxy I watch
Caleb from afar and I'm like he better
[__] talk about 14-year-old things
not like he's 40 years old because he's
[__] 14 right like he and he's got a
ton to add especially like what's
actually happening in 14 to 20 year old
land but I don't think a 47y old in this
room is going to respect a 14y old to
tell him how to live life when he's 14
you need to stay in your lane too many
people want to be something before they
are you got plenty of time for that like
the bottom line is you need to if you're
selling advice please [__] know what
you're talking
about like like like and please as an
audience we need to start understanding
like there needs to me listen everything
can fly everything can fly you can do
anything you want but I'd like to start
employing some common sense wouldn't it
make sense to take a business advice
from somebody that's actually built a
business versus the only business
they've ever had was to give business
advice like doesn't that [__] make
sense to you
guys I don't
know like it [__] makes
sense
attention Arbitrage I built my brand on
email YouTube and Twitter in 2006 or 7
back to the story I built a big business
how did I build it how many people here
have done email marketing in their lives
raise your hand awesome in 1997 I had an
email newsletter for my wine business
200,000 people that had a 91% open rate
wow and 65% clickthrough
I'm no hero though it was because it was
early marketers hadn't ruined email yet
right we didn't ruin it yet I tried and
I do and I'm trying to ruin Snapchat
right now like that's what I do like
show me where there's attention and I'm
a Salesman I want you to buy [__] so I'm
trying to figure out how to sell you
stuff on it that's what I did with email
while everybody else had catalogues then
something came out it was called Google
right I was intrigued by it because they
had this ad product called AdWords the
day it came out I owned the word wine on
Google for 5 cents a click and I owned
it for 9 and A2 months before anybody
bid me up because people still didn't
know what it was how many people here
are actively creating content for their
business and by the way if you raise
your hand I will jump out here pick you
and if you're not actually doing you I'm
going to ruin your personal
brand so ready how many people in this
room are actually producing content
right now for their business on Snapchat
raise your
hand
seven meanwhile it is the fastest is
growing attention graph in the world now
to your credit it is absolutely a 13 to
25 year old thing which may not work for
a lot of you but here's the key it's
like running a marathon if you're going
to run a marathon it's probably good to
run a 5k first if you're going to run a
marathon it's probably good to train on
the treadmill before you do it right so
the reason so many more hands in this
room should have went up for Snapchat
was in 24 months much like Facebook
the far majority of 30 to 50 year olds
or actually I'm going to go with 25 to
45 25 to 42 will be on it and it will
have more attention on it than a lot of
things you've done that same newsletter
on my email service now has a 36% open
rate it's bigger I'm much better at it
it's things I've learned yet it can't be
as good because the supply and demand of
attention everybody has an email
newsletter now I am a million followers
on Twitter because I attacked it in
2007 I wrote it and now it's declining
and I'm not emotional about it I'm
getting far less engagement far less
reach far less business results from my
Twitter account than I did 36 months ago
do I cry that it's over no I do not the
level of crying when something's over is
disgusting like I'm sorry that your
conversion from your affiliate marketing
or your J email newsletters doesn't work
as well get the [__] over it the market
changes nobody cares about your feelings
the market doesn't care the market
doesn't care you care I care but the
market doesn't and unfortunately for
everybody in this room the market is
what matters and so what happens is what
I see from afar is people you know I
always say to my buddies the quickest
way to go out of business is to be
romantic about how you make your
money the quickest way to go out of
business is being romantic about how you
make your money a lot of you in this
room historically have found an
Arbitrage something worked right whether
it was email or Google AdWords or
affiliate marketing or Banner
retargeting or JV or whatever the hell
it was videos on YouTube whatever it was
right joint venture yeah she got you I
said your homies got you um whatever it
is you've found it right right now I
think one of the great Arbitrage
is Instagram influencers right I think
one of the most underpriced things to do
right now is to go to Instagram accounts
that have a lot of followers see them
hopefully they have their Gmail account
in their in their profile which many of
them do because they want the money you
emailed them and you ask them the price
to do a sponsored post and natively and
integrate it and it works extremely well
is by far the execution that I'm most
excited about for my current book and is
doing extremely well because that's
where the attention is and those prices
will go up as people as they get 15
emails a day instead of one the price
goes up it's just these levers I'm
desperate to pound this down everybody's
throat because what's going to happen
over the next 10 years is we're going to
have four to seven to 11 shifts in the
marketplace over the next decade you
will have four to 7 to 11 shifts in the
marketplace if you were doing email
marketing everything was fine until
Google and Gmail decided to create a
promotions tab that wasn't good and
everything was great for the Twitter
influencers like me in 2010 11 and 12
when everybody's attention was there but
then it was gone it's no different than
a hit television show when there's a hit
television show The Big brands in the
world want to run ads and commercials
during that show eventually that show is
not popular anymore and Those ads aren't
as good this Dynamic is playing through
every single day in this Marketplace the
problem is in at this level is people
people are holding on and they're not
educating themselves in what's happening
next and they're making emotional
decisions I love when people tell me
this people like
Gary but you have to understand I didn't
grow up with this
stuff and I'm like you like that that
was a great laugh thank you
uh I'm like that's right Ron but you
didn't grow up driving and you figured
that out right there's way too much
emotion at the 30 40 and 50y old level
that they didn't grow up with this I got
a news alert I didn't grow up with it
either at the time that I was 18 years
old I had spent 20 minutes on a computer
in my life I didn't grow up with it I
just figured it out I love how people
don't realize that putting in work and
learning is one of the requisites for
building a business like literally when
I'm like hey you need to learn Instagram
really what the [__] a matter with you
yes really like yes really yes you have
to learn it's a weird thing you have to
know what the [__] is going on in the
world
yes and so look here's what I see
happening the Market's moving faster
than ever these generations of attention
are not lasting as long Facebook the
reason they created an algorithm where
all of you got mad that you can't reach
everybody it was to save the platform
because if everybody saw everything from
everybody we'd all be gone from Facebook
a long time ago the reason they created
an algorithm is now people are still on
it as a matter of fact people are
spending more time on Facebook today
than 36 months ago because they're
tweaking the algorithm so well it's so
interesting to watch this play out a lot
of other platforms haven't whether
Facebook or Instagram or SnapChat are
here in 36 months from now or not I
don't know truth is I don't care what I
know is that I'm going to consistently
pay attention to what's emerging if you
are not following this narrative and if
you do not understand in this narrative
that one of the most important things to
do is to create quality content and
you've heard this cliche [__]
marketing talk your whole life the
problem is it's true like the problem
with the cliche thing like you have to
produce content that's valuable to sell
[__] the problem with it is it's
true it's true you have to provide value
and more importantly you're only as good
as your last step bat you're only as
good as your last piece of content
you're only as good as that these
logos these logos
you have to understand what's happening
this I think we can all agree that this
is becoming a very important thing in
our lives
right thank you it's my hotel
Key this this is a very important thing
in our lives right and I think this is
quickly becoming the television and the
television is becoming the the
radio now this is super important
because of the following how many people
in this room now in every 24-hour window
including when they sleep are always
within Arm's Reach of their
telephone I mean is literally the
preview of us becoming robots literally
it is so this is the most important
device in our lives do you know how
important this has become to me
literally I would rather somebody roll
up on in New York City steal my wallet
and stab me in the stomach with a knife
then lose my phone that's how important
it
is so my friends this if you agree as I
do how many people here are lucky enough
to have a 13 to 18yearold grandchild or
sibling or uh child in their lives raise
your hand so I think you guys know this
is it no not even the laptop as fact
even me old dude 40 years old I now only
travel with my phone I no longer need my
laptop I do everything on this device
the average 15-year-old in the world not
America in the world when coming home
goes to the room and spends all of their
attention time on this there is no
television There's No Going through
their direct mail there's no [__] like
that there's no going to your landing
page optimization horseshit it's
this and and here's where it starts
getting really serious for me because I
view social media and I know I did my
homework I know where social media sits
in this room as
importance let me give you a quick
preview
[__] social media my friends there's no
such thing as social media it's a word
let me tell you what social media is
social media is the slang term for the
current state of the
internet and when you wrap your head
around that
shift all of a sudden it's not as easy
to just you know kind of like diss it
and if you wrap your head around the
following data you'll start paying real
close attention this is the most
important tool and not just by the way
to 14-year-old girls do you know that on
Instagram the fastest growing demo
taking selfies are 42 to 45 year old
females literally cougar
selfies
so this is the most important device in
the world this is where all of you going
to sell your homes and your information
and your office space from wrap your
head around it that's where it's going
to be sold and now follow me those five
logos and the other seven websites that
are important in social
media they represent
53% of all minutes spent on a cell phone
more than half the time of every
consumer all ages across the board is
spent on those platforms and most of you
aren't doing dick on any of them zero
goose egg and if you are you're mailing
it in you're putting some random
[__] you are playing in a place
where it's email where it's your website
your website that many of you by the way
three of you three of you I don't know
who you guys are three of you when I
went to your website weren't even mobile
optimized weren't even native to a
mobile device and you know who you guys
are you haven't even made your website
work on a mobile device even though in
the next 24 months 34s of all internet
consumption will happen through a mobile
device so I don't know I don't know what
you're waiting for I don't know what
process you're interested in what thing
you're going to do but what I do know is
that you think that your customer is not
on it and they are that's your
vulnerability I know what's happening
you think your 49-year-old Sally and
your 57y old Stan is not on it and
that's who you sell to and that's why
you disrespect it because what you're
doing is you're disrespecting what's
actually happening in the world for
example how many people in this room
have sent an emoji via text raise your
hand raise your hands high I want
everybody look around this is not a
14-year-old
audience except for Caleb this is not
this is this is not a 14-year-old
audience yet 36 months ago most of you
didn't know what an emoji was and now
here we are today 36 months later and
there are 60-year-old men literally
texting OMG and sending [__] emojis to
each
other it's the truth and you know it
because what you haven't realized is the
following what technology is doing is
aging down people guys what technology
is doing right now is it's aging down
people if you're lucky enough to be
sitting here right now and you are of
the age and you're fortunate enough that
your parents are still alive and you're
of the age where you could remember your
parent at the age you are right now if
you're lucky enough right now stick with
me that you're lucky enough to know your
parent that you were a kid and you knew
your parent at the age you are right now
let me give you a preview you are much
younger than they were at this age for
them you should the average
45-year-old's dress and actions what she
spends money on maps a 28-year-old woman
only 10 years ago technology is bringing
our age down quickly and so you will
quickly be on Snapchat because for a
32-year-old woman it's going to be cool
and important to be on on Snapchat in 40
seconds if it isn't have already and in
La New York and San Francisco it already
is got it this is just historical this
is what happens and so what I know is
this entire room wakes up in five years
five I know there's six of you retiring
in
10 but this entire room wakes up in 5
years and your customer that's going to
sign million doll leases and buy three
my entire social network my actual
friends four of them have bought $3
million homes or above through social
media in the last
year my buddy just bought a $700,000
watch from Instagram you know what I
call that
Roi GE one of the biggest brands in the
world we sold a multi hundred million
doll jet engine on LinkedIn not by
spamming them either content if you do
not understand that every single person
in this room is now immedi Media Company
then you don't understand what's
happening if you do not understand that
you were a media company first and then
you sell homes if you don't understand
that you're a media company first and
then you sell wine if you don't
understand that you're a media company
first and then sell clothes or
information or this that and the other
thing then you are not understanding
what's actually happening and you are
going to be in deep [__] [__] and I
mean it because I promise you this my
friends much bigger companies than yours
and I have been disrupted by
technology borders and Barnes & Nobles
were better businesses than yours when
Amazon came along and this is happening
at scale and what you don't know if
you're not completely all in on this is
what happens when there's exponential
scale of maturity the
internet is 20 years old and I know
there's some actually 19 I know nerd but
I
mean I mean the consumer internet when
normal people have gone on it is 20
years old if you look at the growth of
everything that's happened in the last 5
years it is insane yet globally still
only 11 to 14% of e-commerce is
happening on the Internet it's just
started and if you are not adjusting to
this reality you are massively
vulnerable so while this
room spends a lot of time on tactics and
by the way tactics are massively
important I'm pretty aware of the
programming here like tomorrow really
[__] matters those tactics are going
to really matter they matter because
tomorrow matters and next Thursday
matters and the following Sunday matters
right you're living now but the bottom
line is everybody's way too addicted to
the quick tactic what's going to make me
money tomorrow while not recognizing the
macro Trend that is looming if you were
I mean I never I'm con constantly
spending 20 to 30% of my money and
energy on [__] that doesn't have a
prayer to bring me any value in the
first year that I do it that's called
building a brand that's called building
a long-term business that's called
actually building for something more
than the cash flow that I make that year
and that has been the separator for me
in my career that is the separator for
people that win at the highest levels
and even if your ambition stays quite
humble it's a prerequisite to not be put
out of business it's just the way it is
now how much time do I have good um how
much time does he
have I'm going to go 10 more minutes and
I'm going to do some Q&A I want to spend
10 minutes on emotional intelligence My
Friends In America which is the number
one competitive entrepreneurial Market
in the
world to be in the top 1% of earners in
America you have to make $400,000 a year
I really want to start talking about
practicality this whole notion that
everybody has to make millions and
millions and millions of dollars is
insanity we have to recognize if you
actually have the talent to be able to
do that building an actual business
takes Talent you don't get to just build
a million-- Dollar business cuz you read
a [__] book or cuz you want it or cuz
the Secret's going to [__] help you
do it if you wish for it
enough it's not how [__] works there's
no 17-step process if you suck
there's no 17 [__] step process for
me to be [__] the best basketball
player in the world it doesn't exist
there's no [__] 17-step process to
make me [__] Beyonce it doesn't
exist we have to at all costs reframe
the conversation of Entrepreneurship and
building businesses if you actually took
a step back and became honest with
yourself and deployed self-awareness and
understood what you were good at and
what you were bad at I understood that I
was built like a robot that I don't need
to drink that I don't need to eat that I
don't need to [__] sleep well I need
to sleep let me phrase but I definitely
don't need to eat and drink right to
work 18 hours a day and that is my
competitive Advantage I don't work 18
hours a day because it's fun I don't
work 18 hours a day because it's cool I
don't work 18 hours a day for kicks and
Giggles I work 18 hours a day because I
want to win I want something and it is
the thing that I can do better than
anybody I've ever met
I've never met anybody in my entire life
who can work 18 hours a day every day
forever until they die that's me my
brother can't do that nobody I've ever
met can do that and so they shouldn't do
that a lot of people I meet can [__]
destroy it in nine hours and have
algorithmic heads and could do amazing
things and they're the closest people
I've ever seen to passive income because
they run math Arbitrage at scale against
markets and that's God bless everybody
in here has three to four core things
that they're better at within themselves
than everything else they do and the
quicker that every one of you looks in
the mirror and actually has that honest
moment with yourself and starts to
deploy all I didn't say some all of your
energy against those three or four
things the quicker you will maximize
everything starting with happiness
followed by money we are spending way
too much time and energy trying to be
good at things that we can't be good at
it's just real talk and there is a how
big is the business you said I just
heard you how the information business
was how big was
that good that entire [__] business
is built on telling people how to fix
things they suck at when they can't
maximize it that's the truth way too
many people can't get there it is
against everything you hear from
everybody I get it I understand how I
sit on this island very by myself in the
Eco EOS system but [__] man let me say
this think about the thousand people
that are the most famous and successful
in the world and they all have only one
thing in common they [__] punted
everything besides that one talent and
spent every [__] minute in their
lives on that one
Talent that's their common trait now now
does that not mean that you could be the
best entrepreneur that you could be if
you put in the tactics absolutely but
you better be ready to swallow that that
means that you make 87,000 a year cuz
that's a talent that you have you could
made 42 you did the process you put in
the work you tried really hard you
[__] really wanted it and now you
make 87 that's pretty good I can be a
much better jump shooter if I [__]
took a thousand jump shots every day
playing basketball but I still don't
think I'm getting in the
NBA and the reason I'm coming with this
to end is the following not because I
want to be Debbie Downer not because I
want to be like look I'm a really good
entrepreneur and you're not it's because
if you start betting on your strengths
maybe you're just organized maybe you're
a great operator maybe you should be a
number two or number three in somebody's
Oran guys the gal that was number 30 at
Facebook made a fuckload more money than
a lot of us being on our own like
there's a lot of ways to go about it
that aren't predicated on just being the
number one and being that it is an
absolute real conversation that needs to
start happening in entrepreneur land and
business land of actual self-awareness
to strengths and weaknesses it has to
happen it has to happen the data is not
on the side of the current narrative and
so we need to deploy it again you can
absolutely
maximize your marketing skills you can
absolutely be a better copywriter today
than you were a month ago if you
practice and you see the results but
please please understand that practice
tactical optimism is an absolute
blueprint for Success versus blind
hope it's real it's real and you know
what the funny part is most of you know
it most of you know it deep down in your
belly and
so what does it all mean it means that
you only have so much time and energy
and if you can figure out what to deploy
it against you will maximize success and
I think it's a very important time to
start having that conversation because
there is other things that happen
there's tough markets there's downturns
in economies there's other variables and
that's where betting on your strengths
has the biggest
upside so as we head into the Q&A what I
really want to focus on is
attention you know like attention is the
asset it's the asset I mean if you just
spend your time trying to understand
where people people's attention is and
where is it overpriced and where is it
underpriced you will make a lot of money
if your competitors are sending buying
ads and newspapers and sending Direct
Mail while you're doing Google AdWords
and Facebook you will make a lot of
money you just will um as a AA as a as a
like a tactic I would highly recommend
spending a lot more time surveying and
asking your friends and customers what
they do I mean it like you know what's
one of my favorite things to do look at
the home look at actually you know what
everybody do this real quick look at
your phone you know what's really
interesting about your phone this is why
I grab so many people's phones when I'm
traveling if you look at the home screen
of your phone you would be blown away
how big of an indicator the apps on your
home screen are to who you actually
are if you really look at it it's it's
stunning like I can like when I
interview people for like type A jobs I
actually grab their phone a lot to make
sure there's like a lot of like Evernote
and calendars and organized [__] on
there like it is an unbelievable
indicator onto who you are and a great
insight into what that person's about
and things of that nature these are the
places that we need to deploy our energy
attention and self-awareness they are
the rocks of high success in the future
Market thank
you yeah
yeah cool
so I guess it's um so I guess it's Ask
Gary TV show live yes let's do it yeah
for do you do Q&A I don't know hell yeah
let's do it I'm just kidding man 200
shows live we have to to 191 we're up
191 this might be episode 191 if we're
documented well I don't know here we go
what's your name my man my name's Ross
Ross uh Gary you sold me on Snapchat I'm
convinced yes I see the value for
personal Brands and I see the value for
big corporate logo brand yes what I'm
missing is how do I use it as a small
logo brand where I behind the scenes
isn't really that interesting for my my
customers why would it be interesting
for a personal brand but not a small
business I very quick you're just
looking for the excuse in this scenario
it's always the story right like why
would it be big business and why would
it be like one person but not a small
business what you have to do is figure
out how to make the small business
interesting right now the mistake a lot
of people make is they think they need
to be a charismatic individual to help
their small business right the truth is
you need to think about your genre right
there's a lot of for example I know
there's a lot of real estate people I
think the most interesting thing that a
real estate agent can do is own their
territory so for example a small
business an eight person real estate
firm is a small business logo right I
think they should go and interview all
100 people that matter in that town the
principal the person that owns The Bagel
Shop the person that's lived there the
longest in town you see where I'm going
like being a Content producer is hard
but it's equally as hard for a big
business as it is for a person as it is
for a midsize business they're all hard
there's a lot of people the far majority
of people don't win as a big business
the far majority of people don't win as
an individual the far majority of people
don't win as a small business what you
need to do is figure out what the right
story is that brings people value
regardless of where you sit there great
thank you you got it brother questions
hey hey Gary what's your name Kim Kim I
was on episode 172 of the askary man
um my question for you is I'm in
marketing and marketing in business it
seems like a lot of people are trying to
replicate what you do they're putting
out content which is awesome how what's
your recommendation on then standing out
in the field of people that are trying
to play at that
level so I think the way I stand out is
I don't follow anybody else all I do is
follow people and then I'm the first to
report on things and that's my
competitive Advantage I think one of the
mistakes a lot of people do is they
think it's a good strategy to follow
thought leaders regurgitate it and then
be micro versions of that and they pick
up the scraps and they do but you're not
going to stand out because by Nature if
you're following you're following so
what I would tell marketers to do is
actually so I have such a big Advantage
I market for the biggest brands in the
world I market for Wine Library I market
for my own book like I sold 12,000
copies of askar V this week do you know
how many do you know how many marketing
gurus sell 2 3,000 copies for the whole
week when I launch like like there like
if you again this is why I want the
whole Market to become way more cynical
if you go look at the people that are
selling advice and they have a book and
they sell 6,000 copies for the whole
[__] first month there's a problem
because aren't you supposed to use that
marketing advice to sell your [__]
[__] like seriously so what I would say
is go out and do marketing like if
you're going to be marketing advice go
out and actually do marketing that has
nothing to do with marketing advice see
how it actually works and then go report
on how it
works
yeah
okay is it
on just yell testing testing oh there we
go there that one one awesome um what's
your name uh Emil goes I actually flew
down from Japan to come see you I'm I'm
a big fan one the
first thank you so much yeah thank you
yeah and looking forward to reading the
book I downloaded the audio book as well
cuz I heard it's a thank you so
different so we looking for to that okay
um in Japan I do uh a lot of Airbnb
things so right now we're you know
renting out a lot of uh um apartments
and listing them on Airbnb so like
Airbnb management type stuff but our end
user um is comes via Airbnb we don't
really have direct access to users of
the platform so how would someone like a
business like us go about promoting
ourselves um
so how how are you guys organized as as
a as a are you buying the are you
representing the apartment like what's
your act like how's your business
structure oh so so we just we rent
apartments okay um but ra and then list
them and then and then list them you're
arbitraging Airbnb exactly so I think
you need to create a consumer facing
either like again this is and it's back
to your similar question this is where I
love this question this is where I think
I separate myself from a lot of
marketers okay that's what you do but
what you can do is be a level up again
think of content and being a media if
you think you're a media company first
like I I saw a lot of you react when I
said you're a media company first if you
thought like that comma you do apartment
Arbitrage you wouldn't be asking me this
question what you're doing what you're
doing what a lot of people do is you're
thinking about your business and you're
thinking about content as a gateway drug
to a transaction it's number two
if you thought of yourself as a media
company first and then somebody who does
that Arbitrage with Airbnb you'd be
putting out content of the neighborhoods
and the area and the city got it if you
were positioned as a information to
Japan and we have this service that lets
you stay in these apartments your whole
world would be different if you had a
guide of 10 best places to eat sushi in
Japan and that was your gateway drug to
the transaction you think totally
different we have to separate marketing
as a gateway drug to a transaction and
being a Content company so what I would
do if I were you is start doing the tra
I mean you you'd be blown away I mean
absolutely Blown Away by the
capabilities of targeting people on
Facebook or Twitter that are saying
they're going to Japan putting out an
article that says eight great places to
eat sushi in Japan and then using that
as a gateway drug because at the end of
that article or on the left side of the
article or however you decide to UI and
you exit there's a transaction to stay
in your places but that takes a totally
different commitment bro right that
takes you hiring an editor and chief to
be in charge of the content when you're
like what are you talking about I
[__] rent out [__] Apartments Gary
you [__] Maniac you
know and so when I think about the world
the way I see it you know you just
people see the world differently I see
all of you needing an editor-in Chief or
you needing to be that and I get why it
sounds weird for your business to have
one I don't give a [__] I know I'm
right so that's the shift that I see
like that's where I see you having a
real opportunity I would look at those
locations I would take a 10 mile radius
of everything that's around it and I
would become the number one content
producer in the world of every Museum
Park sushi restaurant [__] theater
[__]
everything you got it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah I I see and by and by the way the
advice I just gave you is hard hard
borderline expensive and you've got to
be patient as [__] to get any pay dirt
out of what I just told you you'll hate
me for 18 months and then you'll kiss my
[__] face in
24 got it wow I see my man Scott lachman
here hurting his neck from nodding so
hard cuz that's what he did in his area
man I love
ity works hey how are my name is Georgie
I've got a company called after the
rock.com and I'm a wedding planner
amazing after the rock I like it thank
you. com.au for everyone else
um link it up drock if you're
here um Gary I'm launching an online
program teaching Brides how to plan
their own wedding kind of Marie folio
style in about 8 months smart uh and I
want to go hard on my cont I ask you a
question real quick why eight
months because um I'm practitioner like
I'm in the business with a hell of a lot
of weddings coming up and I really want
to do a massive push with my content and
my marketing before I launch and I want
to give a hell of a lot of and I'll be
testing it it's ready to go I'll be
testing it and changing it as I go but I
just want to be yep launching hard so I
really want to know I've got ideas of
doing well not ideas I've got plans of
um Snapchat series and all sorts of
things but I just want to know how you
would Market it for 2016 2017 so the one
disadvantage I have is I haven't fully
audited the the Aussie market for that
you know we have some clients that do
work here that I have some reads on so I
I don't think people realize Australia
is one of the three best markets for
Facebook in the world like from from the
thing that I trade attention the depth
of interaction per content here is
unbelievable so I think before you get
fancy with everything else make sure you
dominate Facebook because the ability to
Target is so incredible in that
environment
um you know the first thing that comes
to mind right away is what's going I I
don't know but the first thing I would
do if you like if I was like really
working with you the first thing I would
do is audit Pinterest very aggressively
and understand what's happening there
and understand infographics and things
of that nature but I look I think if if
you're at a place where you know to say
drock link it up and you've been
watching my stuff it's the whole theme
of this talk right I mean if you think
about a bride if we're going to if we're
going to generalize that they're not you
know on their second marriage or maybe a
woman that decided to get married later
they're young women for the most part
they only live here like they only live
in the phone they only live on those
places I would say Instagram is probably
an incredibly I that I know for fact in
this market so Instagram is very very
important I think that you should
probably starting now for an 8mth from
Now launch I would Ma I would be
searching hashtags engaged M all those
hashtags and I would start building
relationships right now with women that
just got engaged were engaged in the
last six months just got married because
if they could be ambassadors or things
of that nature I truly think the
attention on Instagram from individuals
is
unbelievable right uh there's a lot of
models in Australia like that I would
even though they may not be engaged or
married I would look at them and try to
figure out what your narrative is with
them I think that's a great Arbitrage um
but it comes down to Quality content
like the fact that you're in the
trenches and actually do this for a
living already has me excited if you
scratch your own itch on content you win
right like like if you actually have a
business that you're building content on
top of I'm very fruitful on that that's
just going to take patience time effort
um and so that's that's what I would say
I mean it's nothing crazy that you
haven't heard yet I think what you need
to do is understand you're not going to
get as much out of it as you think up
front and you just need to stick with it
Marie you know red crushit in 2009 it
took her three years to get into a place
where it started becoming anything sure
do you have do you have the patience and
a tenacity to eat [__] for 36 months is
the game yeah awesome it's thank you for
everything you do too Gary thank you
thank
you hi G you're good H hi Gary I'm Dean
I'm so excited that you're here I love
all the [__] you do and I'm one of the
ones who's supposed to be retiring but
I'm not now because of what you're
telling me I love it um so one of the
questions I have I know that you were
when you did a podcast recently with
James aler and you talked about um the
true the true north of Truth or the
North Star of Truth rather and you said
that people are putting more and more
content out being more and more honest
the way that you do it every day and
then I look at the kids who are coming
up supposedly 80% who all they want to
do is make money and be famous and I'm
thinking well how do those two things go
together because all we're going to have
is these kids who are oversharing to the
point where it's almost pornographic and
it's frightening me at 53 to go well
[__] if I have to go up against that I'm
in real trouble um how do how do you put
those two things together and where do
you see it going 5 years time do we have
to do what you do well no I mean look
everybody has to do what's like there's
no I mean if you're going to map hold on
to the mic cuz I have some questions for
you and I think you might have saw this
in a daily V and you're going to hear a
lot of this out of my mouth for the rest
of the year I have no interest in
anybody doing what I do I have interest
in communicating what I do and then
everybody here is a big girl and boy you
can like look at that and be like all
right here's what I can do that's this
but I definitely don't want to do that
and this and that are you asking me that
because so many people that are the
younger generation that they're putting
out so much content that they're not
going to consume content cuz I think
that's a very popular point of view yeah
it's not only that they consume it but
they seem to overshare about everything
that is out there and and a lot of it is
just [__] I'm not interest no no no a
lot of it may be [__] to you the problem
is you don't get to decide yeah right so
like when the Kardashians become big in
the US and everybody says that's [__]
television the problem is it's the
number one television show on
TV many people in here think that footy
or football or American football is [__]
and that's a waste of four hours but
it's my biggest escapism I said this the
other day we are not allowed to judge
other people's
escapism some people think it's [__] to
stay in line for four hours and wait for
Star Wars other people live for it every
3 years you know some people think I
think it's [__] to read business
books let me let me just say it one more
time let me let me just say it one more
time I think it's a waste of time to
read business
books so you don't get to judge if like
Scandal Cloud girls are sharing
everything because you don't the market
is the market here's what I can tell you
there's a great thing about the market
the bad thing is people get sad when
they hear that part they don't
understand though that the cream always
Rises to the top there's a lot of people
that have tried to do what the
Kardashians have done there's been a lot
of sports there's a lot of pretty girls
and boys like eventually the market
makes its decisions you may not be happy
with what the market picks but it makes
its decisions instead of being crippled
by what everybody I don't even know what
anybody else does bless you like do like
I don't have a [__] clue what Tim
Ferris or Tony Robbins or Oprah or
alisher I don't even know don't even
know and I would tell you as much as you
can take that approach you need to worry
about what you do and what you want to
accomplish
and what you want people to get out of
you and what you want right I have a
friend who all he wants to do is make
$100,000 a year so he can go to Jamaica
and smoke weed right and that's awesome
God bless that I mean I'd kill myself if
that was my ambition right like so you
know everybody gets to do what they want
but I I think you're making a huge
energy waste on trying to decide like do
not judge the market Reserve all that
energy and time to focus on your thing
you will put out stuff your community
will come to you based on what you're
putting out and if nobody's coming then
you're not putting out good [__] darling
yeah okay thanks Gary you got it um Gary
I uh about I don't know how long maybe
five years ago this guy was my Gary ve
then um he tried to talk me into and you
know what I did what you said I became a
good 68 which has been financially
freaking awesome that's right I'm not a
LeBron I'm a really good 68 no because
of his advice but um so this was my Gary
ve before I sort of I played around I
cheated on him man with the guy on the
stage we can
do Gary it's
GV yeah Greg Vincent um I just wanted to
I I've been watching on your wine
library and I saw your book launch at
2:00 the other morning and it's just
just amazing to see um I just want to
ask yes cuz real estate agents were
basically distrusted and distrusted
distrusted in across the profession what
are some of the things you'd recommend
from a a trust based marketing approach
I have a really good idea on this and
this is something that I've deployed to
some friends in the US in real estate
that's really work for them and it's a
little bit and it's fun that you've
watched Wine Library TV it's a very
controversial thing to wrap your head
around so what you probably remember is
I panned the wines that I sold it was my
store
we sold these wines I would sit in front
of a camera and I would say this wine
sucks it's off balanced there's too much
freat you know this and that as a matter
of fact I don't know if how many of you
know this probably very few maybe one or
two in 1998 1999 I was one of the
loudest voices in America about the
whole Barosa Valley explosion in the US
I was a huge advocate I was loved here I
came here A bunch I came here four times
in five years um but then the Barosa
Valley Wines got really too big like way
too fruity way too alcoholic and I
started going the other way didn't come
here as often
um you guys are weren't super happy
about that and uh but it was super weird
and and by the way these were people
that invited me into like I would sit on
camera at one point the show got very
big four five 100,000 people watching a
video where I'm tasting a bottle of wine
and saying it's rubbish
when this was somebody 3 years ago who
let me sleep in their guest room like
very tough [__] but I was always
obsessed with being honest with the
other person I don't think it's a great
way to get listings by making a video
and telling everybody that even though
the inspector will say so I think you
need to replace the roof I don't think
the person selling the home is going to
be pumped with you after they gave you
the
listing however that might be an extreme
version but if you could instead of
saying this is an upand cominging
neighborhood if you're like look this
neighborhood seven years away from
really popping if you're cool with that
great but too many of my friends and I
follow this space pretty carefully are
saying this is the next Brooklyn and
they know in their heart that it's 10
years away so why the [__] are they
saying it because they want the
transaction instead of building the
brand my friends I didn't want to sell
you more wine on Wine Library TV I
wanted to become the world's Wine Guy
and that allowed me to leave that
business day in and day out and it still
does its business while I went on to do
other things had I looked for the
transaction I'd still be there do you
understand do you get it so GB the way
you do it is by telling the [__]
truth and it's really hard when you
represent her and now you're making a
[__] video on your phone and saying
the [__] lawn's a piece of
[__] and so I don't I can't tell you
what to do but I can tell you the
further you get away from the truth the
more likely you're not going to win long
term it's basic as [__] you know it's
true you don't want to do it because it
hurts your short-term money I get it do
you but it doesn't change it it doesn't
change the fact that that's right it
doesn't change it do you understand just
cuz you want it to be that way it
doesn't change
it
you need to be prepared young
lady hi Gary how you doing I'm doing
well my friend my name is Matt thanks
for Matt um the other week you put up a
bartering thing on your book for I can
offer you something and I have to buy a
certain amount of books to make it come
true I offered to be your driver whilst
you're in cityne and they kept saying no
yes so take another swing I'm asking you
now what can I do for you buy books
Sandy hand job whatever's
going to drive you back to the airport
tonight let me hold on let me see I
think they're saying no for a reason let
me see if it's still
there Hustle Man the hand job sounds
amazing inappropriate for good
hustle yeah so this is why my team's the
best the reason I don't um the reason I
can't is that I'm leaving at 6:30 from
my hotel and from 6:30 to 7:30 I'm
dealing with a pretty important business
issue that's a negative it's like they
know that if it's a negative forget it
like I'm trying to hold on to a client
that's not happy I'm just not in the
right mindset to have that conversation
you know what I mean so I apologize
but let me let me let me think don't
I'll talk to you before I leave cool I
appreciate the in a quiet room someone
you know what's funny you know what's
funny is that like it's amazing to me
how much I obsess over tenacity like
there's a real no that I should be
giving you and I'm fighting for you cuz
I just love I and by the way it's really
important to me like I'm Blown Away by
the way the quickest reason that I know
that there's so many not real
entrepreneurs in the marketplace right
now and I'm an investor in a lot and I'm
watching people is a real entrepreneur
just never gives up like like you're
kind of like you know you're kind of
like dead like before you like give up
like like I really appreciate the
tenacity and I appreciate the tactic
like it's not creepy or rude or pulling
up it's just I mean it jab jab jabry
hook how many people read it or know the
Spiel right A lot of people are confused
by jab jab jabry hook and that's why I
started writing articles about it a lot
of people think it's it's so for most of
you that haven't read it it's over there
here's what it stands for give give give
and then
ask you're not not give give give and
then you're entitled like I've given
away 200 episodes of Ask Gary ve and
daily V and answered a million [__]
emails and Snapchat this and this and
that and like all sorts of [__] and then
plenty of people are not buying the book
I just read 100 tweets on the way the
long [__] flight here 100 TW you know
100 tweets of like I I probably got like
literally people that are like I watched
every episode of Ask Gary ve so I'm not
going to buy the book I probably got all
the information literally literally 20
minute shows times a buck 80 and I
couldn't get them to a place where they
wanted to buy one $18 book and I'm okay
with that because that's the market
because the advice I gave you darling is
the same advice I live every day I
didn't they don't want to it's just the
way it is so give give give and then ask
and it's just the ask right that's all
you
get my man hi I'm well hi Gary my name
is Imran from Singapore I flew in from
Singapore to see you as well thank you
um I remember that in one of your
breakout videos you posted this uh
recently the breakout video where you
spoke at the conference in the in the US
and he talked about um growing a
business with their users and then
flipping it is not a business model
that's right right um it's a business
model it's a business model for like 11
people yeah like building a big business
that gets a million users on an app and
then you raise more money and you're
still not making money and you ra it was
a business model for Instagram he made a
billion dollar the problem is there's
four [__] Instagrams and there's
80,000 apps that were deployed to the
app store today that have the model of
I'm going to get a million users I'm
going to raise money and then I'm going
to exit and so so in the context of that
conversation just so everybody's
grounded it is a business model I'm just
not super intrigued by the point
00000000 1% business model I absolutely
agree and I I believe that so many
people in Singapore and Asia need to see
you so my question is how many people
are we going to speak to in Asia how how
many what how many people in Singapore
would you like to speak to all of them
how many would I like to like you want
you want me to go to Singapore with you
you'll drive us we'll get hand jobs
we'll go to Singapore it'll be
great but this uh is that absolutely
serious op so on a on a serious ask we
you're going to love what I'm about to
say um we open Vayner media London next
month yep and I've already I've already
got all the paperwork in place we are we
will be we're going to open up Vayner
media Singapore in the next 24 to 36
months so you'll be seeing too much of
me in Asia and in Singapore
specifically thank you up the
back up the back up the back up the back
up the back C Gary so you got to stand
up my
beautiful hi Gary thank you so much for
coming in today um so my question is um
well today you spoke a lot about playing
to your skill yes and I'm just wondering
how did you find by the way by the way
not only skills strength strength right
how did I find it yeah how did you find
it did just click one day or did you
always know it so for me it did but I've
got different stories I'm the wrong I'm
the wrong kind of like blueprint I
realized it in third grade right like I
basically gave up at school when I was
like 10 years old cuz I already knew
like like this is why I'm trying to
figure out self-awareness like why did I
get so lucky that even at 10 11 I I mean
do you know how tough it is to be
ridiculed and be called stupid at 10 and
11 years old when you know you're
special like it sucked like it was like
talking about eating [__] I ate [__] for
basically most of my childhood my
friends moms literally didn't want their
F like my friends hanging out with me
because I was an F student but I was
spending all my time honing my skill
that I knew I had and I was really
working on it I definitely feel better
about giving this advice than I do
finding self- awareness I would take
every
inclination every passion every
curiosity and I would spend every minute
even at 90 or 9 years old trying all the
things that come to mind and trying them
like literally the guys if you have the
audacity to want to live a highly
Financial successful life if you have
the audacity if you're sitting here I
mean this a business conference I don't
think you're here for [__] kicks and
Giggles I don't think you're here like
to hear music like if like if you have
the audacity to be financially
successful you need to understand a
couple things one it's
rare like it's rare there's not that
many people that have it number two you
need to give up on
Leisure like like if you want the good
stuff like you're not going to be able
to golf every day like you're not going
sailing the whole [__] summer like I
had my first kind of Summer of my life
last year which meant we bought bought a
house in the Hampton we got a house in
the Hamptons and I went there for the
weekends like so you have a lot of time
if you're willing to like if you want
good stuff if you want to be happy and
Rich you have 15 hours a day minimum L
12 where you can do [__] you can work
your job and pay your [__] bills for
seven or eight and then you have [__]
six seven other hours like I always say
this in the US like stop watching House
of Cards like like stop playing [__]
Call of Duty like stop going to every
[__] footy match like no more [__]
happy hour like go and [__] sing and
then paint and then [__] try to
copyright and then [__] be a robot I
don't [__] know but go and like it's
a very easy answer it's very easy to
find your skill go try
[__] it's just that like like I have a
entrepreneur right now whose business is
going to go out of business in four
months he's burning cash it runs out in
four months nobody's giving him money
for his next round cuz funding is
getting tough in the US [__] went skiing
the last two
weekends I don't know what the [__]
going matter with
people like and then I have people that
my friends complain do you know how much
I hate complaining you will never hear
me complain that I don't spend enough
time with my family I made my bed I'm
sleeping in it don't go to Australia for
11 hours if you want to see your family
like I'm like like my buddy's like
complaining guys made hundreds of
millions of dollars I'm having dinner
with them the other night he's like
complain the whole time about not seeing
his family I'm like [__] you go just
spend time with your family like I have
no empathy for your [__] in the same
way that I don't have empathy for my
friends who are like oh Gary you're so
lucky I'm not [__] lucky I [__]
worked [__] worked my ass off I'm
lucky you [__] get home at 5:00 and
do
dick you're
lucky
like I see secretly took this conference
F and I loved your tenacity but secretly
took it because it's kind of a vacation
to be in a plane for 19 hours like like
so to answer your question it's actually
stunningly practical and easy to find a
skill that can work for you it's having
a process that allows you to cut out
everything but trying things for three
months six months two days four weeks
like just try [__] you know it's really
just try and [__] look I'm a really good
public speaker I was 34 the first time I
took the stage but I didn't know you
know it just happened
so that's what I would
do this on uh last one we're GNA have to
do you're going to have to put the rest
hash Ask Gary V we got one more then we
got to do some uh some some stuff at the
back yeah yes um so here pull but guys
if you've got one unanswered # Ask Gary
V there you go man you got your next
have a longer content um Paul good day
mate hello yo I'm on um you've mentioned
some awesome stats in there obviously
you live and breath this stuff and you
do your research um I don't know where
you do your research so like the 53% of
the popul where do you do your research
and keep your finger on the pulse of
where technology and everything's going
in the next few years for me I post game
like I've been talking about the phone
and all this and then people often times
will email me like did you see and and
by the way that 53% it comes from
Forester which is one of the leading
kind of analytics places in the world
but like I don't know what they did like
I don't know if they surveyed a 100
people and then said these 53 like the
truth is a lot of the stats I don't even
care about them like I know what's true
like I know that I'm selling more stuff
on Facebook ads that are mobile than
desktop for wine library right now
they're my stats right so I don't really
care about analytics and stats as much
as most people I know they work for
people I know it's really powerful when
you hear it like I again I thought the
most fun for me today was when I went
through that little social media thing
right where I was like social media it's
the slang term for the internet itself
the current state of the internet here's
the phone 53 I started seeing faces
going [__] man maybe I shouldn't like
[__] maybe this is real right so it's
good for stuff like that but very
honestly I think it's much more
important to be a practitioner and live
and breathe it like I use it as post
game there's no stat that ever made me
do
something and I think that's that's what
I'd like everybody in this room to
understand why are you not willing to
use common sense why were you not
willing three years ago when your buddy
Hank who's 68 and works in the steel
mill texts you an emoji do you not
realize shit's
changing you know I would argue and I
would implore you to understand you're
living your life one way shit's happen
happening and then for some reason when
you put on your work clo you think
something different's
happening and I'll let me save you time
because it's a good way to end the
reason you think something else is
happening when you put your work clothes
on is because you don't want to do the
work to adjust to the reality of the new
market you just don't it's the truth and
I get it do you know exhausting it is
for me to be right after right after
right and know no no no no it's a funny
joke I mean like at this point I've got
a narrative of being right for a pretty
long time and to sit here in front of
you today and know that if I'm not
right in 24 months that it's over like I
don't get to sit at the place where I
sit like you're only as good as your
last at bat the Market's constantly
going to change and so the copywriters
that were the best at magazine that
didn't believe in the internet because
they were making money doing copywriting
in the back of a magazine well they
[__] lost do you understand they lost
cost one great thing for all of you to
read and I don't know if anybody's
written the book on it because I don't
read those things but you can Google
this go educate yourself what happened
when the radios lost the when the radio
lost its number one spot to the
television it's the only thing you need
to fully understand philosophically to
understand what's about to happen over
the next 10 years if you understand that
you will be more mentally prepared for
what you're about to deal with and
please and I'll leave you with this
because I know I'm leaving now
everything that's happened in the last
10 years mobile devices Facebook YouTube
all this [__] it's going to seem boring
and slow compared to what our next 10
years are going to be it is it's
exponential Caleb's generation doesn't
even know about anything else in 10
years Caleb's 24 he may rent an arbnb
and he's not going to know anything he's
not going to know what a banner ad is
like do you know what I mean like he's
not going to know they don't have em
email like they're not going to know any
different it happens
fast don't disrespect it because it will
run your ass
over and wait and all of you including
me were're is disrespecting it right now
and some of you in this room are really
[__] lost and disrespecting it a lot
and here's your business
strategy you're hoping it doesn't happen
you're sitting and saying maybe if it
just doesn't maybe if it just takes 15
years I'll be out and on the
beach the market will put you on the
beach real [__]
fast thank
you thank
you